se eu te falasse que 2020 não foi tão
ruim assim e se eu te falasse que essa
crise sanitária que tá fazendo
aniversário colocou uma massa no seu
rosto fez você se sentir culpado para
abraçar os seus familiares trancou em
casa se limitou não foi tão ruim assim
você fala que eu tô ficando louca se eu
tô vivendo uma realidade paralela que
talvez eu tava vivendo na Nova Zelândia
até agora e só agora voltei para o
Brasil e que você não foi sim um
Prelúdio do que ser ao inferno e que
você nunca na sua vida quer passar por
uma privação assim novamente
e sabes falar assim que essa privação
que você experienciou é a realidade da
vida inteira de centenas de milhões de
pessoas e que no fundo você é
privilegiado
e o que você me falaria
G1
Que bom não é que eu acho que a nossa
sociedade convive com problemas
catastróficos e isso que eu quero
explorar aqui nessa toca mas primeiro eu
gostaria de falar o porquê eu tô nesse
mundo por que que eu tô dando essa toque
e o que tinha emotiva Qual foi o momento
onde eu recebi esse soco no estômago
estou Preste a daí vocês e qual foi o
sentimento que eu tive principalmente
relacionada aquela vontade de visceral
de mudar o mundo mesmo sendo apenas uma
das oito bilhões de pessoas no mundo
poucos momentos foi em 2019 eu fui fazer
um curso de sustentabilidade a
globalização em praga na República Checa
e na minha sala tinha basicamente gente
do mundo inteiro e a gente tava
discutindo um paralelo de fotos de duas
senhoras e um lado uma senhora da África
Subsaariana ela tinha um pequeno
comércio de frutas e ela basicamente
teve seu destino traçado na maternidade
onde ela é muito provavelmente teve que
parar de estudar numa idade muito pouca
E chegou a ir para escola e realidades
como andar vários quilômetros para
buscar água em baldes e trazer no
próprio lombo para sustentar a própria
casa é algo muito comum e muito
provavelmente que o que limita a vida
dela desde então a
o outro lado a gente tem uma senhora da
religião muçulmana ela tá usando em Fabi
Até que a gente chama erroneamente de
busca Tá mas aquela vestimenta preta
tradicional da religião deles somente
aparecendo os olhos e ela tinha joias em
torno do pulso e tava segurando um
smartphone a gente tava fazendo um
paralelo sobre questões de que ambas as
fotos retratavam que era pobreza tá de
formas diferentes e que a pobreza nada
mais é do que violação de direitos
humanos básicos e o que são esses
direitos acesso à educação acesso à
saúde acesso a mobilidade liberdade de
escolha acesso a saneamento básico
energia elétrica e por aí vai você tem
mais ou menos um coro de vida que todas
as pessoas deveriam receber assim que
nasce nasce mas que infelizmente está
longe de ser a nossa realidade
se você gente tava conversando e
discutindo ali naquele ambiente um rapaz
Arábia Saudita ele levantou muito
chateado com aquela discussão ele
levantou a mão e falou que de fato não
estava se sentindo confortável com
aquelas colocações E aí o professor
muito pacientemente falou que a gente
poderia não acreditava no ambiente
democrático e poderíamos discutir como
estava se sentindo E aí ele começou a
ficar cada vez mais agressivo dizendo
que não concordava e as mulheres da
região muçulmana eram de alguma formas
eram de alguma formar reprimida e eles
vão pegar todo o material dele e não
somente embora daquela aula mas como
embora da escola inteira ele nunca mais
voltou isso Acabou me dando o primeiro
soco no estômago o que é de falar sobre
direitos humanos já é um assunto que
incomoda incomoda bastante
bom e é isso que eu queria me tirar aqui
levando vocês para dar uma volta ao
mundo com as maiores estatísticas que a
gente tem hoje é com relação ao
desenvolvimento sustentável hoje existem
cerca de oito bilhões de pessoas no
mundo tá vamos arredondar para fim
didático eu tô representando cada bilhão
de pessoas
um por um personagem por boneca então é
que a gente tem a senhora com suas duas
netas a gente tem dois pais com o seu
filho e a gente tem um casal
culturalmente diverso ou seja se a
família tradicional brasileira aquela
famosa bom aqui a senhora ela tá
representando quase um milhão de pessoas
que hoje não tem acesso à educação
básica elas não sabe nem ler nem
escrever elas são que a gente chama de e
literárias ou seja se ela vai no mercado
e tem uma promoção do leve 3 pague 2 ela
não tem noção do que isso é ele como que
ela pode ter vantagem em cima disso
e as netas por sua vez representam quase
2 milhões de pessoas que não têm acesso
a uma alimentação de qualidade essa
alimentação não tem a quantidade de
micronutrientes que elas precisam para
se desenvolver de uma maneira saudável
duas milhões de pessoas fazendo os
cálculos é oito populações do Brasil é
muita coisa seguindo ali no bonde do
desconforto a gente tem o o casal
culturalmente diverso que representa os
dois bilhões de pessoas que não têm
acesso a água própria para consumo não
têm acesso a água própria para consumo
dessas duas milhões de pessoas cerca de
um milhão e duzentos mil pessoas
e elas morrem morrem todo ano de
diarreia
a promoção do que foi isso Eu moro em
Curitiba a minha cidade tem mais ou
menos Dois Bilhões dois milhões de
pessoas você contar com região
metropolitana são três é metade da minha
cidade morrendo todo ano de diarreia é
uma doença que você consegue prevenir
facilmente tá bom aí nós temos a pior
estatística de todas quer que eu
gostaria sinceramente que eu tivesse me
equivocado e colocado aqui um número
totalmente trocado que a seguinte mais
da metade da população mundial mais da
metade da população mundial não tem
acesso a saneamento básico tá eles não
tem seu lixo recolhido de forma ótima e
eles também não tem acesso a uma
descarga por exemplo você vai lá faz
censitário fisiológicas e você não sabe
para onde ela vai e você nem quer saber
eles não tem um
e talvez você esteja pensando agora que
eu inventei todas as estatísticas né que
eu tô te dando todo esse desconforto
para que você paga e sai dessa toca e
pense puxa vou fazer minha parte para
que não chega esse tempo talvez você
esteja pensando que tem usando essa
técnica certo Cara infelizmente não eu
queria estar mentindo eu queria estar
inventando eu queria estar falando para
você números totalmente aleatórios
estratosféricos para que a gente se
conscientizasse não deixaram chegar
nesse patamar mas a realidade é que eu
estou aqui justamente para mostrar o com
o estar e o quanto isso vai piorar se a
gente considerar que lá em 2100 a gente
vai ser uma população de 11 milhões de
pessoas mais três grandes que vai fazer
com tanta gente
e como que a gente vai gerenciar tudo
isso
Ah tá
é exatamente nesse momento no auge do
nosso desconforto dessas estatísticas
que eu quero apresentar o protagonista
na nossa Talk que ao empreendedorismo de
impacto social o que que é um
empreendedor de impacto social é uma
pessoa que pague seus boletos como
proposta Divina é uma pessoa que
adiciona Um item no como de vida
daquelas pessoas que precisam
Ah tá é muito importante estabelecer
aqui o seguinte empreendedorismo de
impacto social não é filosofia essa
pessoa precisa ganhar Ela precisa lucrar
é uma empresa com qualquer outra é uma
Startup como qualquer outra a diferença
é que aqui a lucratividade e o impacto
social eles são tão importantes quanto
eles andam sempre juntos na prática como
que isso se dá tá então vamos pegar o
problema da energia elétrica hoje das
800 milhões que eu falei lá atrás que
não tem essa energia 600 milhões ficam
na região da África Subsaariana essa
região ela já é conhecida como ser como
sendo uma das regiões mais pobres do
nosso planeta
E para isso masterkap lançou uma
iniciativa de instalar painéis Solares
em residências esses painéis Solares
eles tem altíssima qualidade baixíssimo
custo E para aquelas pessoas que não
conseguem de fato pagar por aquilo
existe uma linha de micro financiamento
e deixa isso mais forte e bem mais
democrático Afinal algo que o
empreendedor de impacto sempre tem que
pensar é que a pessoa que ele vai estar
vendendo as coisas muito provavelmente
em várias situações vai viver ali No
Limiar de pobreza ou de algum tipo de
violação de direitos humanos como a
gente falou lá atrás e aqui é o quê que
vocês perceberem o quanto instalar um
painel solar no centro de uma residência
pode mudar completamente a realidade de
Uma Família primeiro porque agora eles
vão ter acesso a um lugar
eletrodomésticos na parede e isso acaba
refletindo a possibilidade de
conservação de alimentos de outra
maneira entre outros até ter acesso à
informação que agora você
o rádio você pode hoje ter expande a sua
atuação no mundo tá é com isso a gente
também diminuir os riscos para a saúde
porque hoje para ter uma mínima
iluminação dentro das casas eles ficam
querosene dentro de lampiões e isso é
muito problemático porque imagina você é
um ambiente fechado queimando
combustível somente nocivo para a saúde
horrível mesmo melhorias para a saúde
Outro. É
E com isso a gente também tem impacto
ambiental porque afinal não tem mais
gente queimando querosene na atmosfera
Olha que bacana e uma obviamente
economia para essa família porque ela
não paga mais por esse combustível e
também hoje ela tem a possibilidade de
decifrar economia porque Digamos que uma
senhora que trabalha numa residência
hoje pode alugar uma máquina de costurar
e fazer ali sua fonte de renda principal
uma venda que só funcionava de dia
porque não tinha iluminação agora pode
se transformar no bar e aumentar sua
lucratividade contratar outras pessoas e
além disso a sensação de segurança de
instalar painéis Solares tanto em
residências quanto em cidades aumenta
muito porque eu acho que todo mundo aqui
já andou numa rua que tinha uma
iluminação boa e numa rua que tinha uma
iluminação ruim essa sensação de
segurança na que abrem iluminada é
extremamente diferente então eu queria
que ficasse de reflexão aqui é um quanto
um painel solar consegue mudar a
realidade de pessoas de famílias
e inteiras Esse é o objetivo principal
de um prendedor de impacto social e
é que agora eu gostaria de abrir o
parênteses mais importante da toca e se
for para você se levarem uma informação
daqui que esteja essa
e aquelas pessoas que podem estar
pensando ouvir a pensar e os
empreendedores de impacto social não
deveriam estar cobrando porque essas
pessoas elas já veem alguma situação
vulnerável Eu gostaria que você se sente
assim seguinte o que é preferível você
dá uma oportunidade uma pessoa que não
família que uma comunidade inteira se
desenvolver e formar o forno através de
micro financiamentos ou deixar elas à
mercê de um governo que aparentemente
esqueceu já elas ou pior ainda deixar
elas na mão de terceiro e podem dar isso
para elas em troca de exploração de mão
de obra barata ou até mesmo é de
exploração de recursos naturais
e o que que é preferir nesse caso Porto
grande diferencial do empreendedorismo
de impacto social é que sim os
resultados financeiros são tão
importantes quanto o impacto social em
cima porque na prática Isso se traduz
primeiro em pessoas trabalhando em prol
de pessoas trabalhando em prol de deixar
nossa sociedade no lugar melhor segundo
pessoas trabalhando orientadas a um
propósito porque hoje em pleno século 21
e ninguém mas admite ir lá numa empresa
Bater cartão embora só para pagar suas
contas no final do mês as pessoas querem
mais do que isso elas querem propósito
elas querem sentir que elas estão
mudando a realidade vetores de parte
social da para as pessoas justamente
isso fico com isso a gente aos poucos
vai deixando filantropia como
coadjuvante na sociedade porque como eu
disse lá atrás Sim ela é super
importante a gente precisa que ela
continue mas a longo prazo a gente
precisa sim de soluções mas
é porque a gente pode ficar esperando
filantropos igual Bill Gates resolver
todos os nossos problemas a gente vai
chegar lá em 2100 com problemas muito
maiores do que aqueles que a gente já
tem hoje sem sombra de dúvidas Então se
você tem o poder de escolha de tá
assistindo essa toque hoje interpretar
as palavras que saem da minha boca não
dispositivo com acesso à internet Luz
elétrica e se você tá fazendo tudo isso
sobre um teto sobre a sua cabeça teto
esse que se você for ali no banheiro
você liga o chuveiro e vem água de um
lugar que você não andou 5 km para
trazer para sua casa deixa eu te contar
uma coisa você é muito privilegiada
muito de verdade e a pergunta que fica é
como que você vai usar esse seu
Privilégio para mudar um pouquinho
sociedade é deixar ela só um pouquinho
melhor do que você encontrou
G1